i'm sure you're having the same
experience that i am
of people saying
the most remarkable things to you
they'll stop you on the street and you
know
they'll look you in the eyes they want
you to understand what they're trying to
say and they will say things like
you are keeping me sane all the time
right it's it's an extraordinary
experience to go through that even once
yes
if it happened to you once in your life
once in your life yeah it would be
enough yeah but when it when people are
repeatedly saying
that the fact you know you've that
you've let it be known that you think
something and i realize that i think
that too and that means i'm not even if
i am mad
i'm not the only mad person there's at
least two of us right and but then you
really but it ripples out
and
all these people i that's what i mean
when i say it's distilled down to
fundamentals for me
the the fact that i'm in contact with
her i've been contacted by people from
new zealand yeah from the other side of
the planet and everywhere else in
between from every continent i've had
letters and communication from people
who've said you've worked you've gone to
all sorts of effort to get a message to
me to say i think that as well
and it means so much to me to know that
someone else thinks what i think
it's profound
it's been i'm a different i've been i've
been made a different person
on account of
covert 19. it it's such an even that is
i don't know what covert 19 is i don't i
don't know what it's for i don't know
who did it and why
but it is a key that has unlocked
something for me
yeah it's it's beautiful and i will also
say there's another dimension i don't
know if you will have seen it but
um
so there's sort of two categories of of
people in
the dissident movement right there are
people who are recognizable you you and
me for example
and
then there are people who regard
themselves as anonymous and frequently
their first assumption is that they are
unimportant
right they will often introduce
themselves and they will not mention
their name and i will always say who are
you right because
that's not the way to think about it
you've just joined a small group of
people and
what what is this anonymity business
right
but
the number of
absolutely extraordinary people in that
anonymous group is amazing right i've
met some of the smartest people the most
capable people
who show up just as a person in a crowd
at first and then it becomes clear to
you over a few interactions wait a
minute this is a very special person
right and anyway some of these people
have become close friends and and allies
in the sense that you know when that
term used to have a real meaning uh and
that's delightful too just it's like i
when i used to walk into a classroom the
first time you know that i met my class
at the beginning of the year
i would look out at the sea of faces and
i would think
there are people in here that you know
nine months from now i'm going to
realize just the depth of what's going
on in their minds and it will be it will
be a beautiful thing to know them but i
don't know who they are yet you know and
it's that thing that just
like a sea of human discovery is now
available because this thing has forced
very unique people together and anyway
it's a joy
[Music]